there's a new glass and steel Sentinel
in the City of London the Leadenhall
building oh the cheese grater all the
developers are giving me a guided tour
welcome to the building as you go up you
can see this fantastic public open space
that we've created co-developed by
British land and Oxford properties the
cheese grater isn't like other
skyscrapers for one it was prefabricated
and assembled by a tiny crew on an
impossibly tight city block it's like a
giant Meccano set how are you even
getting the building materials who's the
city yeah well it's very challenging 80%
of the the building has been
prefabricated off-site a lot of its
being built in the north of England and
then it's been railed at there and
actually driven into the city often at
nighttime more than half the office
space is already rented out with tenants
due to start moving in early next year
fantastic space must be able to charge a
pretty big premium for it now if you
think about typical rents in the city
for crime accommodation being 60 pounds
of square foot we've already achieved 72
pounds 50 per square foot on some of the
lower floors
so here probably over 80 pounds a square
foot
london's skyline is changing faster now
than it ever has seven towers are
scheduled to be finished in the next two
years more than 230 are in the pipeline
for the next decade
it's an extraordinary building boom
that's being stoked by demand for office
and residential space you've got a look
at a place where you can compete and we
think has the long-term ability to
generate those returns and London when
you start to go down and tick the boxes
on that list London really is the
obvious first place for us bets are
paying off for developers who took the
risk and started construction despite
the financial crisis rents for
skyscrapers are climbing faster than
regular office space and demand is
outstripping supply London has needed
this new wave of towers in the last 12
months you have seen the level of
available office space in London fall by
8 percent driven down by companies
taking more space as they become
confident about the outlet for their
companies this is really we believe the
center of Europe if not arguably that
from a financial perspective the center
of the world
Caroline Hyde Bloomberg